Have you heard of the higher-dose brand of Infrared Soda Blakets, an Infrared P.M.F.
fan? If so, what is your opinion of them and do they help with cancer? I wondered also
the difference between the infrared heating pad you have on your website for $160 and the
one for $198 to either of these help reduce tumors. And would any of these options serve the same
function as going into an infrared Soda? Trying to determine the most economic way to address
the cancer with infrared. Okay, so do you get benefit from the infrared heating infrared
heating pad for cancer? My opinion, no. So the only purpose for you to use an infrared heating pad
would be for the source for a heat source, not for an infrared source.
You're using the heating pad to heat and give you some deep heat for the purpose of,
you know, if you have a cold or you have pneumonia or if you have an infection, heat could be real
beneficial so that we're talking about a heating pad right now. Or I highly recommend using the
heating pads over your liver, over your gall bladder. It could help decrease the viscosity of your
bile. It could help move things through your liver. So there's huge benefits to the heating pads.
Now what heating pads should I use? I just use an electric heating pad that my mom used to have when
when I was little. No, because those have just heating coils in it can cause eAF issues.
Or not really good for you. Well, then what's a good heating patch? I just use one of those
microwaveable packs that, you know, you know, that you microwave for three minutes and well, those are
really nice, but they don't hold their heat for very long. So, and not a very, you know, much of a fan of
those except maybe on the go or something like that. Then what should you use? Hot water bottle? You can
too, but how water gets cool and it doesn't hold its heat very long. That's why I like those infrared
heating pads. They don't have the electric coils in them that are going to cause any eAF issues.
But let's be honest, they're not really putting out much info around. So there's really not much
info red benefit to them. So, but it's a better source of heat. So which one should you use? We have
two of them. One that's a little cheaper than the other. Actually, I personally use the one that's
a little cheaper. That's the one we have at home. That's the one we have at the office. That's, you
know, we've given that to our kids for Christmas presents. I think they're great little units. I really
like those units. I would go with the least lesser expensive infrared heating pad. Up to the top
question again, if you heard of the higher dose brand of infrared soda blankets and the infrared
KeMF pads, I don't think they're worth their money. And they're certainly not something that's
quote unquote cancer. I would not spend my money on those. And then the bottom paragraph, would any of
these be options that serve the same function as the infrared sauna? No, not at all. The purpose of
the infrared sauna, again, is not to give you infrared waves. You're getting very little true infrared
for the infrared sauna. The purpose of an infrared sauna is to cook you, is to make you sweat, is to
help you detoxify and bypass the liver and the kidney, help you to use the organ of your skin
as a detoxification pathway. That's the purpose of an infrared sauna. They are not in this, it's not
even in the same category as the first two paragraphs. So again, all the purpose of infrared
heat pad is to produce heat over a specific area. The purpose of an infrared sauna is to make you sweat.
So if finances are an issue, like don't have a thousand dollars to spend on a sauna, just get a
heat pad. Let's get the infrared heat pad. Don't spend the money on that infrared PMF mask.